[Music]
my name is guy
sunday should be warm and sunny just a
scattering of drive-bys
and i live in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work
at the bank everybody
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a cold fish there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that
put these on okay fine oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something guy
there is no easy way to say this this
world it's a video game
you're not real please
[Applause]
and the stop responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time
now that's not real i don't know what it
is i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy thanks
guys i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity
off you go this whole good guy routine
is ruining the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
that actually hurt my hands we can save
our world
but we have to fight together
time's up bank teller
[Music]
nope
i can't die i'm never gonna die
well they say kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help i'll get my coat
30 years in the future we are fighting a
war
our enemy is not human and we are losing
we need you to fight
i will be back and i love you chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
you won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world
all right yeah going to war stop talking
listen
sorry i mean i'm nervous at talk i'm
like 97 on the nervous scale
that should be fun
welcome to the future you and your unit
are now
in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster and stronger than you can
possibly imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous i feel like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the face of
the earth
nothing we do here matters
that's where you're wrong i don't
believe that one bit
together we can stop this war from ever
happening
this is my opportunity to give this
world a second chance
second chances are really hard to come
by
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it
in the cabin the bullet goes in thing
and everybody sucked out
are you a good girl
you're a dirty little girl
who's in charge here what the hell do
you want at my crime scene or the fbi
i'm with the state police
give me a shout i'm supposed to be
protecting these girls it's not your
operation
you belong to me you understand what i'm
saying
now lift up that skirt no
the minute i got made bait it became my
operation
i have communication with over a dozen
active offenders
we had a bonafide serial killer
i kind of think i'm looking for you
i got a girl with a skull cracked in six
places the bite marks
it matches another girl vanished
from a truck stop outside of pensacola
last night
stop it there who's that
get up it's purification time
who was he trying to cuff one of my
girls he had a lightning bolt on his
truck
he's hurting some girl right now
i can set him up again
you sure do look familiar
not never get such a pretty face
do everything that you can
folks now you live alone i just want to
keep an eye out for you
you're gonna get me killed we'll have a
little party
don't you worry we'll have our time
together
[Music]
it wasn't your fault
[Music]
i had his hand
[Music]
you might see a whale or a shark
okay we're going down
what the hell was that we're sitting
fast
we're floating around in this piece of
plastic junk
if the shark is still out there i'd rate
our chances at all surviving
less than five percent
so do you think it's gone it's still out
there
that's close
we can't give up we can still survive
if we do nothing we're done
where is it it's got to be out there
somewhere
welcome king james
i'm a cartoon
[Music]
the computer dude kidnapped my son
what in the matrix hell
hey what'd you do to my son the only way
you're getting your son back is if you
and i play a little basketball
you want to play me in basketball
i need to assemble an elite team you
need a dream team
i'll take it from here sam shoot the
ball
let's try that again shall we we'll get
your son back
i promise what's happening
i look expensive introducing
the ghoul squad
you're about to lose your family
well at least we're good oh and i almost
forgot
all of the tunes will be deleted so
come on guys the toon squad doesn't give
up if we're going out
we're going out looney
you gotta win this game and get our son
back
pump up the chance let's go twos i got
coming off the bench
widely coyote the machine's producing
multiple wiley coyotes
well that happened wow
[Music]
we need a boost a secret weapon come on
man granny's out here having a martini
at halftime kate is gonna hate
happy anniversary pumpkin things have
been bad between us
and i'm sorry i don't know when surprise
isn't gonna fix everything
i love you with all of my heart
till death do us part
i'm impressed you made it this far
there's one final surprise
happy anniversary pumpkin
we're not leaving until we open that
safe 200 grand in rocks we split the
diamonds
let's go two people knew the combination
to that state
the guy who hired us i'm the girl
she could be miles away by now
she's still in the house
[Music]
i wanna used to get hurt he wants you to
scream
please a perfect couple
i'm gonna cut myself free of you if it's
the last thing i do
we've studied outer space more than the
earth
[Music]
what happened
where are the others
everything is just like in a regular
shaft
but later on you'll see what we actually
created here
this form of love is unknown science
it's the end of the human race
[Music]
[Music]
we're not even invited to this thing
aren't we nope
[Music]
uh mom's coming benjamin have you two
been smoking dope
yeah why can't you keep him under
control sons and hannah christmases
given
for generations the given and wrath card
families had
a blood feud it was never about business
your son is trespassing
it was personal marry rascard and
give it do i need to explain to you why
this is unacceptable
end it it was an
instant scandal you take care of my
problem
i'll grant you my daughter's hand
take care of him looks like man you're
gonna dance
how do you wanna die i wanna die in a
gunfight
the choices they had made had led them
to this very moment
the fallout it's not going to be pretty
let's get out of here i always thought
of my life like i was living my movie
i'm going to be the star of your movie
this presents me with an issue keep your
friends close and your enemies close the
right dad
enough we're gonna piss a lot of people
off
do you have a death wish something that
excites you
dudes pretty much conform or die
honestly i'd rather die
put the fear of god in it will try to
stop us
i'll protect you
for as long as you want me to how about
forever
what do i know that you need so bad
that's why you're here
to find out
[Applause]
you're not crazy you never have been
do you find yourself drawn to places
you've never been
the visions you've had your entire life
aren't hallucinations
they're memories you're talking about
reincarnation the legend never dies
we call ourselves the infinite we
remember skills from
all our past lives it takes 10
000 hours to master a skill how could
you be after a million hours
pretty damn good
what do i know that you need so bad
that's why you're here to find out
we have fought one another for centuries
but you can't stop what's coming the end
of all things
is he blocked well well well we're gonna
have to reset your memory
you're gonna drown me i gotta think
about drowning which is i don't like it
you know what man i like you this time
around shut up and turn it
[Music]
kill them on
there's still time time
no more time
did you see that
have you ever made anything fly
[Music]
do you want to try it
uh my name is detective hawthorne i've
been dispatched to follow up on uh
a report of potential witchcraft at a
bar a few miles away from here
may i come in
where is it
[Music]
ready yeah
imagine a device that is the fastest
most advanced
complex piece of technology in the world
but what if it wasn't just a device
what if it was your new best friend hi
introducing the bee bot it connects you
to the world like never before
express yourself imagine without limits
create play and enter a new world
of friendship the bee bot let's make
friends wow happy late birthday barney
oh
dad you got me one
[Music]
hi insert registered name i am your
your your my bee bot
be bought
the bee bot there's there's something
wrong with it it's not meant to do that
i'm not meant to do that
i am for making friends does barney need
friends well yeah or fun fact he will
not survive middle school
[Music]
six
i am insert registered named best friend
out of my box
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you said man won't see me ally
can't come in here what is he white
[Music]
oh boy so what's the score
we're sending a man that works in an
office to pick something up
you are part of a babysitting team
watching his family while he does it
good morning everything is normal
except what do you want is that
something you'd say
normal monday i'm gonna shoot you right
now
can i go home now wait at the house
after what do you mean after
we're right off of you
what is going on big guy yeah what are
we doing we're following
instructions are you helping me or are
you not helping no no no no
thank you set up man
god called me offering me ten thousand
dollars
turn you in
[Music]
i'd like to listen to the
you right now radio crime like the muff
well i guess that's the 64
000 question it's been a long day
i'll put this over you so i can relax
thank you
work i don't think that's the end of
that
chicken now
the problem is you're not smart enough
to know how not smart you are
which makes you unpredictable which
makes you untrustworthy
why are you doing this man cause i'ma
get what's mine
sorry i'm gonna punch you now sir i'm
punching you
this is going to be a punch
tammy faye what'd you do hello mother
this is jim baker
my husband
it's all part of our mission to help
people anyone who's hurting or they feel
like they've been left out
god has planned for us what'd he tell
you to do this time
jim will preach and i'll
god sing not want us to be poor
a pleasure now god has a voice in this
fight
who's he fighting liberal agenda
homosexual agenda
faith isn't political you can't talk to
him like that
jerry falwell is a powerful man tammy
faye she's a firecracker jim
[Music]
if everyone watching could double their
pledge
just for one month god loves you
he really does
we're not doing anything wrong though
is that a question
[Music]
tammy and i are undergoing the most
vicious attacks
serving god don't feel like it should be
a money-making opportunity
you know when i saw that clipping with
my face on it i thought for a second
that you were proud of me
oh tammy faye you follow blindly in the
end
all you are is blind
i just want to love people cry every
night the devil's coming for me tammy
can we talk about satan leader
steve is a patient of aids i can't look
at this you need to get her under
control
i built you an empire i built you an
empire
some people they're just hurting so bad
and we just need to love them
i want to put my arm around you and i
want to put my arms around you tammy
i won't go for it looking in the
rear-view mirror of my life
this is who i am
[Music]
huh